net migration to the UK has hit its
highest level since the second world war
the office for National statistics says
more than half a million more people
came to the UK than left it last year
largely driven by arrivals from Hong
Kong and Ukraine the ons also says 35
000 people cross the channel in small
boats in the year to June although the
ministry of Defense says the figure hit
40 000 last month and there were more
than 63 000 Asylum applications the
highest since 2003. our data and
forensics correspondent Tom Cheshire
joins me now Tom what do these figures
tell us oh yeah tell us a few things
it's important to separate that net
migration figure doesn't include the
Asylum applications it doesn't include
those small Boat Crossings this is the
overall pitch at 1.1 million people
arrived in the UK giving that around a
half a million people stayed and it is
the biggest record uh since we started
keeping records uh proposed War the
previous high was 329 000 that was in
2015 and what we love about is how much
immigration has changed uh post brexit
back in 2015 the largest proportion of
people coming to the UK was EU systems
that has changed dramatically today 61
percent of people coming to the UK are
non-eu Nationals actually there was a
decrease in the population 51 000 EU
Nationals left the UK in net figures
last year so it's really really changed
those people coming the majority of them
are coming on student Visas so the
question is how lasting will this be
most students do leave at the end of the
Visas but the office for National
statistics also making the point this
has been a pretty extraordinary year
we've had the opening up of travel
restrictions post pandemic so that's
letting people come especially if they
want to study and things like that but
also when we think of what's happened in
the world Ukraine we've got Hong Kong
and Afghanistan those numbers account
for nearly 200 000 of that so it's the
question of whether those people stay in
the UK whether they will return home and
then there's the wider a debate around
this whether immigration is good for the
UK we heard from the Prime Minister and
the lead of the opposition they both
were pretty Negative they wanted to cut
down on the numbers uh kierstama saying
they want to end the immigration
dependency on the other hand uh the
office for Budget responsibility has
said a lot of it's factorization of the
growth of the UK is based on high
immigration uh helping UK productivity
so there's very different ways of
looking at this but as I say a record
number coming uh to the UK 504 000
people